foreign
you know what dude I was at a show the
other day and I was doing a meet and
greet and this guy came up to me and he
was like nice to meet you man he says
these sunglasses original grain boom
that's what he did and there are these
dude so check it out original Green and
he was styling man those look good look
the favorites are all still here but
they sent us a brand new burlwood silver
44 millimeter Chrono dude and uh oh look
at that bad boy yeah it's got some
weight to it and uh this thing's got
some beef on it
the tag uh yeah it's got some weight to
it you look like a real man that look
look at how carefully the sleeve just
folds on over it yeah so look
it's made of rare and rugged burl wood
larger watch face great blend of style
and functionality and it comes with a
stopwatch Timing System and a calendar
date function what else could you need
um so it can be engraved with a
personalized message it's perfect for
Christmas weddings anniversaries
birthdays and uh goes perfect to pair
with our burlwood silver tungsten ring
uh these are back in stock they sold out
immediately and they did it with our
listeners so this is how you do it you
uh go to
originalgrain.com
lifeline and you type in the code
Lifeline to get 30 off
site-wide that's 30 off all right that's
a lot percent off that's code Lifeline
at originalgrain.com
Lifeline to get 30 off site-wide and the
link is in the description below in the
show notes so if you don't want to type
it in go click that
Lifeline is an advice show for
entertainment purposes only if you need
real help or advice please seek a
therapist or licensed professional
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
I guess welcome back if you're an avid
listener but also we didn't start yet so
we're starting now so you don't say
welcome back so you just say welcome and
welcome back to lifelines no
everyone watches okay and you have then
why don't we have seven billion views on
YouTube
YouTube is Shadow bending us well so
that means that they're not being seen
no they're lying oh they're lying
they're fixing it they're fixing the
number one show in the world the fix is
in yeah got it okay you have two purple
hats now I do you you so what the deal
is you have too much of whatever you're
doing remember the too many drinks thing
and let me curb that and now you have
too many
I've let it be known that I only wear
purple no I know except on weekends and
holidays that's fine and that has
expanded into the worst it's called
purple stuff the worst cult leader I'm
not a cult leader but you don't just a
man that's what collators say yeah
yeah they do they do so look guys let me
just get into it the Don't Push Me Tour
it's live January we are doing so many
freaking dates it's unbelievable dude
February March we got Chicago we got New
York we got [ __ ] San Diego we just
added a show in San Diego because the
[ __ ] the demand is there we're doing
this Springfield Missouri where the [ __ ]
is it but we're doing it and um we're
doing a bunch of different uh places so
what do you think about that Midland
Texas what the [ __ ] Savannah Georgia
Raleigh North Carolina what the [ __ ]
Lakeland Florida what the [ __ ]
constantly getting surprised okay so go
to chrisley.com to get your tickets the
good seats are filling up and let's do
it my babies you know what you know what
what show has all good seats the [ __ ]
Lifeline live first ever Lifeline live
show on my birthday tickets October 19 6
p.m
uh 6 p.m Pacific time oops and you know
that's how we're doing it
the link is in the uh
uh comments below so go click on that
link or go to watch lifeline.com and
let's do it up and you get a ticket and
we provide if you want secret one-on-one
private advice you go to mattdelia.com
you book a private session with your
pimp and pimp and purple boy Matt Delia
that's me 20 or 40 minutes or Tuesday
whichever one you want you book it on
there I tell you what to do you live a
life that is very very happy from then
on dude the a w a WWF 80s wrestler the
pimpin pimpin purple what is it purple
boy yeah boy
purple Boy versus Hacksaw Jim Duggan
tonight on RAW uh yeah it's you yeah I
would be so good at that with two hats
oh he's changing his hats that's my
special move uh oh he's changing his
hats you know what that means
all right so um so that's what's up when
we're having a good time here on
Lifeline what the [ __ ] dude yeah when
it's getting Breezy out right it's
getting cold that's your new thing me
and maybe say what the [ __ ] yeah it's
getting cold last night was real windy I
went outside and I was like whoa no
that's crazy no it's not oh it's crazy
that it happened yeah okay so it is it
is finally uh cool out at long last
that's why I got a beanie on it you know
what's cool is that now Calvin's at the
age where he kind of knows what's going
on and Halloween's coming and uh
Christmas is coming and he knows what's
up like I say you know Santa's coming do
you want to have presents and he goes
like that like he wants presents he's
real wide-eyed about it yeah and I said
what do you want to be for Halloween and
he says a football people eater he wants
to be a purple people eater by the way
you could probably give him some yeah he
loves that song he should get a load of
me yeah he does get a load of you he
says
map really map yeah oh that's cute yeah
well he does now he says Matt a little
bit clearer but he used to say unga map
so he asked me what he was like what is
this and he held something up it was
styrofoam and I said styrofoam and I
said oh it's styrofoam and he said
styrofoam and I'm like that's cute I was
like it's like um ah whatever and then I
left it came to life you know what we I
bet we know
at least a dozen people that's that's
still styrofoam wow dude
that's so dumb it's Unique to people we
know we know truly some of the dumbest
[ __ ] I know on Earth dude I
love dumb people yeah because then you
stand out because you don't seem as dumb
Booyah but that's not true oh yeah and
that's not true do you know why because
dude when I'm hanging out I just want to
chill dude I don't want to talk about
[ __ ] [ __ ] that matters I'm gonna talk
about cargo pants and just like you know
what kind of [ __ ] turkey do you eat
and that's what makes you dumb
and Booyah from the ropes
boy having a [ __ ] stroke I think dude
I think that it's not that and I'm not
dumb and I'm actually smart and I'm so
smart that I don't need to talk about
the smart stuff because I already
realized it so let's get into some cargo
pants from the top ropes okay the thing
about you you're this guy you are not
dumb what's tragic about you and that's
that you so let's get into it seem dumb
because you don't apply yourself
Booyah boo yeah
and Booyah that's so [ __ ] annoying
but I'll tell you this much dude none of
that's true I [ __ ] just apply myself
and you know when I do stand up I I
excel because I do it and I'm very good
I'm very good with my words you're very
and I perform very very good at that
because it's instant gratification you
couldn't do anything possibly that
required a little bit even medium-term
gratification it has to be instant
immediate gratification or else you
won't apply yourself because you don't
see the longer term or mean even
medium-term goals as viable
the closest
not the words not even words
and it kind of kind of funny
Rankin Donuts sad Rankin tiny sad
Mad World
Mad World worst shot of all [ __ ] time
balls are great man they're in Oregon
yeah Aaron Aaron Darren Aronofsky yeah
Darren aragonovsky
um I saw a [ __ ] Hellraiser the new
one then saw you know how I do it if
you're a [ __ ] my brother what did I
do after I saw the [ __ ] new
Hellraiser you saw the first one and
then even all of the ones in between
which if I didn't because that would
have taken you 48 years because there's
30 000 Hellraisers 11 Hellraisers
oh this is the 12th one this is the
eleventh one now were you saying the
original is not good it doesn't hold up
it's just like yeah it it I mean okay
well you're wrong I mean look I like the
idea a lot yeah it's a great idea is
great the concept all is awesome yeah
it's just it's not something that is
really that good and I I agree with that
but the first one I mean I haven't seen
all of them granted but I think of the
ones I've seen the first one is the best
one just because the premise is like new
and they're exploring it for the first
time and it's not anything like they're
not like forcing it yeah I mean well
they're not forcing it that's for sure
but also that was when SNM was like kind
of a thing that was like what the [ __ ]
is this right and then so they they made
this whole like you know these people
from a different dimension that like
pain is pleasure and [ __ ] and they can't
tell the difference and also those those
demons are [ __ ] [ __ ] up and scared
really well done yeah like bro horror I
mean they can do it really well um but
the thing is is like after the first one
the second one it gives you a little bit
more insight into it so the second one
was like okay so I'm like this watching
the second one I'm like the third one
then in 1992 it's a fan favorite but I
go like this I just don't sing so oh
yeah I'm not into that one dude I mean
it was 1992 and I was just like I don't
know it was a good year though for
movies in general yeah I know and the
woman in that is so hot unbelievable
okay why is it Ashton sing so because
it's so 90s and like Camp kinda I like
90s though I know I like 90s too dude
you're talking to a 90s boy I mean
you're talking to a sincere 90s boy I
mean I look at the 90s and I go like
this okay yeah now we're talking yeah
but you don't like that much [ __ ] from
the 90s nah I do
I do I do and frankly I tell it like it
is all right so speaking of Hellraiser
my mom is a hell razor speaking of
Hellraiser speaking of the first part of
that word hell yeah Hollywood California
you know you know what it is yeah
Hollywood California has turned into
hell I sound like I'm a [ __ ] anchor
on Fox news but no but you can't turn
around on any Street and not run into
either A [ __ ] massive encampment with
crazy people circling around or a burnt
down encampment where people are just
sitting around like it's a [ __ ]
picnic okay the other day I was [ __ ]
I was driving through and this wasn't
even deep in Hollywood this is pretty
far east which is where I usually am if
I'm um at all yeah and I stop at a red
light and I and I see
a crazy person
and how do you know she's crazy
crazy eyes she got the crazy eyes that
are like look they look like they're
looking different ways even though
you're not a doctor but you're saying
okay and she's walking Jagged zigzaggy
okay she could be drunk okay and here's
the real Telltale this is how you know
they walk
exactly when they're not supposed to and
they don't like when they cross the
street yeah they cross the street
exactly when it says not to right and
they stay put exactly what it says to
cross the street okay now then now I buy
this now here's another way I knew
because I saw her coming I thought oh
great she's probably gonna [ __ ] with me
because that's the story of my life who
does she [ __ ] with me she stands right
in front of my car now it's a green
light okay she's going like this
I mean [ __ ] uh
Harry Potter and her eyes are all going
all different directions Voldemort but
here's the crazy part drunk Voldemort
she had no shirt on like a bra
no no shirt or bra
like just the taters were out
Tannen having a day dude and then when
she was doing this [ __ ] the boobs would
go and fluctuate
so she go wow
was it hot at all uh was it hot to look
at or was it no it was hot outside no
but was it sexy I mean don't be gross
I'm the one that's gross she's in the
middle of the street with the [ __ ]
she's gross I'm saying of course it
wasn't like sexy I know I don't think it
was but I'm wondering if you think it
was she looked strangely not at all
dirty too
like usually she was a homeless person
or just a French person
she thought she was at a nude beach yeah
no she was crazy you could tell a look
in her eye okay so she was going like
this at me though and pointing at me you
know and then when she finally moved on
she just she just did one of these like
like it was like it was me who was the
crazy one like this
and they just kept walking oh that's the
true sign of crazy
yeah like I failed to live up to my end
of the bargain you know what I mean
she's just like this
you were supposed to jump
I wish I knew what I was supposed to do
I would have thrown it back but all I
did was I swear to God all I did was
this
yeah yeah well what can you do when
they're shaking it I was trying to not
like I wanted
I didn't know what she was doing but I
wanted her to know I wasn't like
disapproving or angry or grossed out
even though I kind of was all of those
things what if she did that and you just
go like and then you were like I don't
know what I'm supposed to do so you just
went like this
what do you think she would have done
like [ __ ] oh I [ __ ] and I knew it
I don't think she would have even
[ __ ] noticed honestly yeah yeah you
know yeah okay well
and that's how I roll that's a shame
I've seen naked homeless people before
it's because dude I saw a guy in La once
and this was before the pandemic and
everything went to [ __ ] but I saw a guy
walking down the street
just dick out naked no clothes like he
was shopping just like at Target just
walking like kind of Swing his arms a
little bit just fat and just walking
down the street and I'm driving I go oh
my God dude so he wasn't uh like a crazy
nudist he was he was a homeless he had
to be crazy but it he did not look crazy
right if he was just walking with
clothes on would not have thought he was
crazy so you saw his dim boss flapping
oh yeah okay okay I drove by and I was
like no yeah and then you turned around
drove back pictures anyway and you took
pictures yeah if I was a cop
and and that happened yeah you wouldn't
you were
go ahead yeah he didn't see it no no
freeze no no I'm not I don't imagine
freeze because he's naked freeze put
your dick in the air
uh yeah I mean I used to live downtown
and dude the [ __ ] I've seen oh my God
one time just one more time before we
get into this [ __ ] uh we like the banter
when I used to smoke there was a [ __ ]
crazy woman across the street there was
a little grassy park across the street
from my building and and I walk out and
I'm talking to a friend of mine out
there and she [ __ ] surprises me comes
out of nowhere and she just goes
and I was like oh my [ __ ] God yeah
and then I I'm looking at her now
because I didn't see her coming up it
was like she was a ninja yeah and but
she's close as hell right oh wow yeah
there you go close yeah and so and I
said what she goes
and I'm smoking I realized okay she's
playing here and I say you want your
cigarette okay and she goes
okay I don't know what you're doing you
know so I kept talking to my friend and
then she starts like doing this like
kicking her feet up like a bull like
she's ready to come at me and I'm like
well she's not gonna [ __ ] hurt me
right you know what I mean so like
whatever uh and now and I back up enough
to notice
her pants are around her ankles and her
[ __ ] all of her business is just out
loud and proud right and then I'm like
oh and I kind of step back like just in
shock yeah yeah and then she gets like
offended that I step back in check and
she starts coming like oh my God oh my
God but she couldn't take big steps
because her feet were already and I was
like coming back I was like stop stop
yeah yeah yeah like laughing and it was
just real depressing I gave her a
cigarette though was it sexy it was real
hot we dated first dude also you didn't
really try to get away if she couldn't
take big steps you could have just
[ __ ] ran I was just slowly back
pedaling laughing I wanted it you kind
of wanted some I was enjoying what you
wanted to get I was thinking about like
telling you and telling people that no
no no no no Oh no
just in place yeah yeah you take your
pants out too I can't go either
um
so maybe was it a center bite could have
been that woman though yeah was
filthy like layers of layers of layers
of dirt on her
like the woman the thing behind
behind the dumpster and move on drops
wow dude okay yeah all right well let's
get into it that was a lot of banter but
we hope you liked it we don't really
care but we had a good time so let's go
to some Lifeline in the news guys here
we go Matt why don't you read it a man
claiming to be a Russian astronaut in
space allegedly scammed the Japanese
woman into paying for his return trip to
Earth vowing to marry her once he landed
this is from Vice believing this man
would be her future fiancee the woman
paid him about 4.4 million yen about
thirty thousand dollars in five
installments from August 19th to
September 5th the Japanese newspaper
yamir shimben reported but when his
demands continued the woman grew
suspicious of his intent and reported
him to the police who are investigating
the case as a romance scam local media
reported a romance scam Intergalactic
romance scam dude
dumb Intergalactic romance scam
romance scam Intergalactic dude I I
this is the thing dude scams are are
shitty you can prey on people and make
them scams like I watch this HBO Max
[ __ ] documentary on scammers and
these guys really go out of their way to
make people feel like you know
comfortable and good at giving money and
[ __ ] like that those people uh you know
those people deserve to pay some sort of
penalty or whatever this guy yeah
figured it out she should pay some
penalty for being so [ __ ] dim hello I
am in space I need to get home I need
you know rubles or whatever the [ __ ] the
Aruba is whatever the [ __ ] Russian
money is yeah and four 4.4 yeah oh it's
Japanese she was in Japan
oh my god dude yeah like imagine this
guy just like
If I Only Had thirty thousand dollars
and also how did he find this woman like
yeah here's the thing about the scammers
whatever obviously they're [ __ ]
villains that's [ __ ] service up there
but the people who get scammed was it on
Zoom yeah the don't get scammed dude oh
dude it was dumb ass [ __ ] dude it was
the zoom with the space background
it's just like this he's just like this
doing it like just like like
having the wallet flow so you can't see
his hands yeah he's really just some in
Moscow somewhere you know what I mean oh
my God they saw early and I need five
grand
I need five grand alien allergic to Yen
please need rubles need anything you
need yeah I mean the advice here is any
flat bottom line anybody who emails you
that you don't know no you do not give
them anything information further
further than that the advice is never
trust somebody on the internet period
yeah even someone you do know because it
might not be them yeah yeah yeah yeah
and if they want money no
this is crazy dude how are the cops
going to get him though in outer space
it's hard it's hard so you can turn
Galactic please
like this
yeah he's gonna get away dude
[ __ ] it
so [ __ ] stupid
[Applause]
I mean you're taking it's taking so long
because the space is slow that's the
bullet
oh all right
next one from the guardian morning New
York University oh I [ __ ] read about
this New York University Professor fired
after students say his class was too
hard that's great Maitland Jones Jr a
professor of organic chemistry was fired
by NYU after more than 80 students from
his 350 student course signed a petition
complaining about grades teaching and
help received during the covet pandemic
dude
um
the complaining about school by students
especially when it's about class being
too hard
is the [ __ ] most annoying thing on
top of which
the [ __ ] uh Administration fired his
ass that's crazy also it's NYU I know
it's a it's a [ __ ] it's supposed to
be hard I know it's College it's NYU and
dude it's like imagine if this was like
a doctor like a doctor class for [ __ ]
med school it'd be like it's too hard
and then people just [ __ ] yeah
exactly no that these people probably
pre-med some of them I know the thing
about this [ __ ] is like this is I've
said this for a while dude the customer
is always right mentality yeah is
driving our society into the [ __ ]
ground yeah dude customers [ __ ]
rarely right yeah dude the customers
never right yeah customer's never right
so I think it's crazy I think devices
stay in school and don't complain about
it or [ __ ] don't try to get up these
petitions are [ __ ] annoying and [ __ ]
so oh 80 people signed something yeah
that's not even close to half
we'll sign something about the school
being too imagine being this [ __ ]
poor guy also if you don't want a thing
to be hard don't study organic
chemistries study like take clowning in
101 or some [ __ ] dude imagine this class
is too hard I'm going around here like
dude I I swear to God I I really really
really knew I was inside a [ __ ] box
and the guy said I wasn't inside a box
and gave me a d and I think it's amazing
I mean check this out dude
yeah well nobody would fail someone that
does that yeah
[Laughter]
sign it did you did you do clowning yeah
yeah
so hard I didn't complain and now look
dude yeah now look at you yeah this is
where this is where not complaining gets
you folks yeah dude look at this
huh what
what is oh yeah yeah okay great great
job
all right all right uh what do we got
new let's keep doing these two videos
now yeah new videos people it's already
20 minutes in the show you got people
here we go my babies
hey Chris and Matt huge fan of the Pod
Chris please come to Minneapolis I will
so my question revolves around College
room
I live with two other girls one who's
very laid back in little
brother who's very sensitive and
emotional
um our sensitive roommate is the type of
person to be offended and think everyone
hates her if she's not invited to one
little thing
um and so last week I went to a hayride
with my boyfriend and his friends and
invited my laid-back roommate because
she's talking to one of his friends and
our sensitive roommate had plans um and
now she is flying off the handle at me
for not inviting her slamming doors in
our apartment stomping around sending me
nasty text messages obviously so deeper
for her yeah
um and I don't really know how to handle
it because it's just an extremely
hostile place to live right now
um should I try and sit down talk with
her she's kind of the type of person
where you're damned if you do you're
damned if you don't
um and so I'm just kind of like at a
loss right now I don't really know what
I should do or say or if anything but
thanks guys I really appreciate anything
I know what to do victim mentality dude
I know what to do
she's invisible
and nothing she does can even make a
sound anymore so she just act like she's
not even [ __ ] there like it's not
she's ready to talk to you about it
slamming doors and making a [ __ ]
scene yeah the others just she's a ghost
it's so hard just so hard to do though
don't give it don't give an inch you
know you did nothing wrong don't bend
over for this [ __ ] person that is
clearly I don't know if she's spoiled
deeper yeah she's got issues but who
knows dude like she's still young
hopefully she'll figure it out a lot of
people do at that age they're like such
[ __ ] babies and all they want is
attention but uh you're not going to do
any favors by giving like uh
giving like credit yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah
the whole idea of I I can't stand this
the whole idea of you have to invite
every friend to everything you ever do
or if you're a dick is unreal sometimes
I don't want to invite David Sullivan oh
I don't ever want to invite this right
because he's a [ __ ] guy who is just
you know his skull is physically big
head he's a friend with our of ours he
looks like Thomas Jefferson no yeah he
looks like the guy what was it the head
head the guy within it from MTV
so yeah dude I don't it's like yo you
just got to be like I didn't I I invited
the chill laid back friend because I
wanted to invite her you were busy
anyway and also I didn't want to invite
you also I wanted to have a chill laid
back time not an uptight yeah [ __ ]
brat time yeah I I think honestly if if
you you can have a conversation one time
with her and if this continues it's just
going to be one of those situations
where you gotta she's out it sounds like
she probably has tried but to no avail
and if that's the case no more yeah
she's invisible that's my advice to you
she is now invisible okay yeah I mean
you can do that pretend like she's the
others yeah I am your adult that's
that's David I don't even barely
remember that you don't remember that I
kind of remember that was this [ __ ] dude
I loved it on call though it looks just
like David Sullivan yeah
um so uh yeah but you don't have to can
fight all your [ __ ] friends imagine
you have to fight all your friends all
the way I got four tickets to the Dodger
game I gotta [ __ ] I gotta do a mass
text at 35 people the first four people
like it's like do micro machines guys
but like I just I dude it's so annoying
because like you just you invite who you
want to invite and that's okay remember
when you guys always okay it's always
okay to invite whoever you want to
invite a year and a half we were in the
text chain and a year and a half you
guys one of you guys was like when are
you coming over and I was like oh what
are you guys doing on a game night I was
like oh really and like you said yeah we
do game night every week I didn't even
know for a year and a half you've been
doing game night I don't even know thank
you for knowing me that well but like
nobody would ever invite you to a game
night yeah because it sucks dude no
because no because you suck no and you
don't play games I know the truth again
oh I don't play games where am I I don't
mean where am I you know yeah I don't
know
somewhere where there's a rope
so uh
so anyway dude yeah I just you gotta
she's gotta get to step into it you move
or she moves you gotta get this stuff
and get a [ __ ] two bedroom with a
chill friend I mean that's a bit much
just ignore her I know but okay until I
mean she could make her life a living
hell I guess but she's not she's just
she's throwing a tantrum okay yeah she
keeps swinging Tantrums I'm just saying
okay
I remember if it doesn't say much let's
go to the next one
now a word from our sponsor better help
better help
it's one word better help like that oh
but you can do better help to you know
really drive it home I was trying to
drive it home I get stuck uh focusing on
problems instead of solutions you know
like sometimes my mind gets spinning and
uh how like uh I don't realize that my
mind my my situations would be better if
I had a different mindset therapy helps
me with that and better help is a great
example of a way to do therapy uh now
especially in this day and age it can be
tough to train your brain to stay in
problem solving mode when faced with a
challenge in life uh so you find your
own Solutions uh there's no better
feeling trust me uh and the therapist
can help you become a better Problem
Solver making it easier to accomplish
your goals no matter how big or small if
you're thinking about giving therapy a
try better help is a fantastic great
option it's convenient it's accessible
it's affordable and entirely online you
don't have to go anywhere no it comes to
you yeah uh get matched with the
therapist after filling out a brief
survey and switch therapist us at any
time yeah so if you get a goofball what
you want because better help has good
you know vetting system but if you get a
goofball for you you get to Boom change
it immediately uh and but the not
battling traffic thing is the best part
therapy saves lives period it saved my
life so uh when you want to be a better
Problem Solver therapy can get you there
visit betterhelp.com
Lifeline today and you will get 10 off
your first month that's better
help.com slash Lifeline do it
you want to read it
hi Matt and Chris I love you and I love
Calvin too okay I am extremely
embarrassed I'm one of my early 30s and
I still live at home with my parents and
younger brother the other night I was in
bed watching some
naughty videos
I had my airpods connected of course
what I was completely unaware of was
that my phone was also connected to the
Bluetooth speaker in my all caps parents
bathroom
I didn't know your phone could be
connected neither did I do two devices
at once but apparently it can crying
clown face my regular face oh regular
crying face uh my mom confronted me the
next day to ask if my phone was hooked
up to the speaker and I checked and
still unaware of the major atrocity said
oh yeah oops it didn't hit me until she
said I noticed it last night
shock face I want to die I want to fly
to outer space and never return I want
to change my identity and only wear wigs
from now on what do I do do I leave it
at that do I confront her about what
exactly she heard please help shoot me
love you now just honestly this the
advice I have is you didn't do anything
wrong no you didn't you made a mistake
by having your parents hear that [ __ ]
but you didn't mean to
um but like the whole shame of it is
like you don't need to feel that there's
a very human emotion but like you don't
need to feel that because honestly it's
just sex it's not even sex it's I mean
it's sex but it's like naughty videos
and you're a [ __ ] grown-up you know
yeah she says she's 30 right yeah yeah
you know you're 30. in your 30s like
you're a full ass adult you can do
whatever the [ __ ] your mom directly in
her eyes and say my bean needed
attention am I what you look at your mom
right in the eyes and you like say it
like Mr Mr Anderson in the [ __ ]
Matrix okay my bean needed attention
what what are you saying being my being
needed attention yeah what's that what
looks like a bean on your body in
between your legs like a coffee bean
okay no no well
it looks like a lentil bean up top I
don't think it looks like it looks like
a coffee bean the actual thing looks
like a coffee bean but I'm saying oh oh
the lentil bean up top
lentil bean oh okay
there's a lentil being on top of a
coffee bean if you know what I'm cutting
there's a big coffee bean it's like a
Russian doll of beans there's a there's
a big coffee bean but I'm saying actual
sized lentil being above the big coffee
bean that's the bean that needed
attention really because I got it that
was pleasure LL Bean okay so what you
need to do
is realize that your mom also needed to
attend to her being at some point uh
that everyone in the world attends to
their beans that's why in all the old
ass [ __ ] religious texts it says
nobody is allowed God said nobody's
allowed to play with their beans yeah
okay it should have been everyone loved
you know it's okay to attend to your
beings
tender beans
wow that's good the 11th commandment and
it's okay to attend to your beans you
shall always attend to your neighbor's
beans all the Commandments have to do
with their neighbor you know yeah yeah I
know that's so weird just make sure you
are not hooked up to your neighbor's
Bluetooth as well yeah only be hooked up
to your own Bluetooth when it attend
when being attentive to your being or
just attending to your beans right
I think I got the language right yeah I
mean it doesn't really matter because
it's not real but yeah
okay anyway okay just own it dude you
[ __ ] attended to your being and you
got caught I needed to lightly move my
being around also what's with the mom
yeah I noticed like what a dick dude
she's just she got all pent up she needs
to [ __ ] hang with her being a little
bit dude you should send her the video
uh air drop the video to her and say
yeah being attendance is required yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah that's true being
attendance required comma mom yeah
being attendance in the email
she sees this to other people and gets
she's just so bad with technology oh no
all right yeah for sure all right I'm
gonna take a pure Spectrum gummies dude
huh keeps me level-headed baby oh you
know it's always been one of my least
favorite things that you do but you put
something in your mouth you go keep your
love ahead of babies [ __ ]
[Music]
pure Spectrum CBD the link is in the
show notes go down click it hit Lifeline
for 10 off of all your CBD needs my
babies and also dude let me tell you
this okay put it in the show description
because Chris didn't ER [ __ ] last
week yes dude all right let's do it next
one
hey Chris and Matt from New Hampshire
big fan of the podcast thank you so my
question is what are your thoughts on
people putting their feet uh at out car
windows as passengers
I think it's completely okay I love
doing it on back roads
um it's kind of vibing uh my
brother-in-law and I are in a debate he
thinks it's unacceptable
um and I think his only valid argument
is that it's a safety concern
um but I think you know you run the risk
of getting into an accident every single
time you get into a car anyways
so why not just live your best life and
then just not be fearful you're gonna
get into a car accident every single
time
um I think he has an aversion to feet
he's not admitting to uh in society I
feel like feet it's very divisive you
either fetishize them or you have like a
strong aversion to them and I think this
question is kind of right down the
middle
um I think it's fun putting your feet
out the window Chris am I not allowed in
the Log Cabin if I like putting my feet
out the window what do you guys think
you got to be your true self but let me
tell you something there's a few things
wrong with it I have something to say
okay go ahead okay uh normally I'd say
do whatever the [ __ ] you want because
that's what I say to everything but
honestly the safety concern is real I
was I was driving in my friends I was in
the passenger seat of my friend's car
this is in high school this is Nick
marquan's car well boy Nick farquief
remember uh and my arm was out the
window just like doing whatever the [ __ ]
and I was telling him a story and as I'm
telling the story I I'm I'm articulating
with my hands and I bring my hand and
then just to do something like that and
right when I bring my hand in a car
on Foothill Boulevard a car was backing
out of a parking spot and just ripped
off his rear view window and it was like
a split second after I brought my arm in
I remember so like of course do whatever
you want but when your foot gets knocked
off by a pickup truck backing out on
Foothill Boulevard I honestly just love
that country only it's only your fault
when your foot gets knocked off on
Foothill Boulevard while someone's
reversing yeah yeah keep your hands
inside and get down take it down keep
your legs inside didn't get down so
shitty people either have a virgin to
feed or they fetishize them
down by the way people finish this
feeder just Niche niched yeah yeah I get
it what I do is I put both out
I go in the center farting I go in the
center
[ __ ] seat as I call it so uncomfortable
and I go both out but here's the thing
dude I think it is a safety concern and
I don't really like John May in high
school used to be like I don't wear a
seat belt I'm driving if I die I die you
know what I mean and it's like that's
not no dude so I you know it is a safety
concern you got to be on the lookout if
you have the foot out you got to be
[ __ ] wary you know Pull It in if a
car is going to hit it but also this is
the Annoying Thing doing it when you're
driving okay I understand if you're
flexible and you know me do it
I'm a flexible string beam right so I
drive and I keep it out and I rested on
the [ __ ] side mirror but I will tell
you this if you're the backseat it's
annoying as [ __ ] because dude you're
[ __ ] driving and then all you got the
[ __ ] foot right there so that's why
if he has a version of Feed he looks at
the foot it's right there that's [ __ ]
kind of annoying it also you could think
it's a little gross exactly well if you
have no I mean she probably you know
chicks they don't wear they wear like
flip-flops sometimes and [ __ ] I'll be so
do guys yeah but no but chicks love to
do that kind of [ __ ] on like the back
road you know what I mean the back road
imagine a girl wearing a closed-toed
shoe on a back road with a foot out
there's no way it never happened in the
world no they do because they don't get
snake bit no I said yes they have boots
but they put them on out I'm telling you
dude the most casual women love the
Casual [ __ ] dude I said yes okay okay
uh and that's that okay I just think may
maybe do it you know
not so so much maybe get it out the way
in a parked car
if he has an aversion defeat he thinks
they're gross you should listen to him
because that's just respectful that's
not his real if that's not his reason
then [ __ ] him keep your feet out the
window wow you laid the hammer done huh
yeah it's either or it's like the foot
aversion or fetish all right okay I get
it extreme one way it is stop it is cool
that I can do that though huh yes I mean
it's it's like fine it's kind of okay
it's on a cool side it's on the cool
side yeah okay next
hey Matt and Chris my name is Evan from
the Sacramento area nice guy and my
question is about Hobbies so
basically I'm of the mindset that if I'm
not immediately good at something I'm
not going to continue pursuing it
um and so that means that I don't have a
lot of things that I'm interested in
yeah so
do you guys think that I should
keep pursuing something even though it's
difficult and I don't like it
immediately but I might find out that I
like it down the line once I get good at
it
or should I just cast a huge
net
and just try a bunch of things out and
figure out what I'm immediately good at
pursue those things uh let me know what
you guys think that's interesting I
didn't think that's what he was going to
say as a second option it's a good
question um I would say because you're a
person you have tastes you have probably
have a better sense than we do about
what you might like yeah so if if you're
bad or good at something you take to it
right away or not
do you like the thing does it seem like
a lot of fun if you were to master it if
that's the case then stick with it even
if you suck it's not like to me it's not
either or it's like the opposite of the
previous question there's so much
fluctuation and possibility here if you
are good at it or not if the thing seems
really really fun to you and what your
brain likes and doesn't like but he's so
apathetic about [ __ ] he's saying you
know he doesn't like that many things
because he feels he's not good at things
or but here's the other thing but you
get good at things the more you do them
is my point I know but you also have to
look at it this are you a perfectionist
because like
you know I'm good at stand up and like I
I was good in the beginning but if I go
back and look at videos of me it's
terrible it's interesting so like so
like was I good I mean
technically no I remember you being good
but now when I watch videos of you in
the beginning I think you suck no
so now that would be rude right but no
no I know you're joking but like I
wanted them to know okay that's sweet of
you but let's you know it's okay I'm so
upset but yeah no I watched video of me
doing stand up in the first six months
like after like years after I started
straight up Open Mic no it was a show
it's like one of those okay and I was
like oh my really I turned it off I
couldn't watch it so like you know maybe
don't be so hard on yourself as my
advice yes that's good advice dude
that's always the best but don't be so
hard on yourself man and try some things
but don't this whole cast in a wide net
like people who are like you know I want
to try and experience different things
to find out who I am those people are
[ __ ] weird as [ __ ] yeah I agree I
agree like dude you kind of should know
what you like already if you got hair on
your face you should know a few things
that you like yeah
so it's like dude I don't know man don't
be one of those dudes that's like yeah I
gotta [ __ ] walk Barefoot all the way
to you know what I mean what's the deal
with people not wanting to do things
unless they're good at them like that's
that to me is on the same is that the
same thing but it's not the same
wavelength it's trying to get a teacher
fighter because the class is too hard
it's like the thing is the thing you
want to be good at it work yeah to being
good at it if it interests you keep
working at it you [ __ ] what are
you just like only want to do things
that you're good at that's so boring oh
also there's a boring person there's
something to be led said about like your
life leading you to something that you
like and like I have a buddy who would
like do a lot of animation and it never
really like got successful off it but he
loved you know him but he does like a
lot of Animation yeah yeah and not not
your friend no I know so and um and he
never really got he was very good at it
never made a career out of it and now he
like he's always liked movies and [ __ ]
and now he likes to like he makes these
like prints of like themed old newspaper
like I could say like 90s horror movies
and he's got a bunch of newspaper
articles like for scream [ __ ] Friday
13th or whatever and he makes them and
you could get him framed and like he
makes prints of them and sells them dude
and he loves doing it and he's like it
took me a while to find out my passion
but this is awesome people pay me to do
this [ __ ] I love doing it and I'm happy
and if this guy was out here trying
[ __ ] Racquetball and rock climbing it
would have taken even longer to him to
get to this [ __ ] thing it's so time
consuming too yeah you got it home yeah
things you might like right not just all
things right right yeah anyway yeah so
that's what's up I think yeah don't be
so hard on yourself yeah next one yeah
what's happening to live Brothers my
question is about friendship basically
when I grow short I had to make a
decision to get the vaccine
make a move in my place of work to and
try and increase my money because I just
got engaged a year ago nice
congratulations um and also have two uh
daughters all right so you know times
you're getting they were getting a
little rough for me
um New York has been rough with the
whole pandemic stuff yeah especially in
the service industry is where I work so
yeah anyways um so a friend of mine
basically implied and believed that
getting the vaccine was like getting an
STD like HIV and the vials and you know
all kinds of crazy [ __ ] and you know he
basically took me off everything and
basically ghosted me and him and his bro
were supposed to be in my wedding and I
just I've tried to try I've wanted to
take the high road but I just don't know
what to do you know so would love to
know how one would handle this because
he got the vaccine his friend won't talk
to him anymore is that what he said
that's okay that's crazy here's the
thing about the vaccine in the pandemic
in general we know this firsthand and I
know of many if not almost all people
probably have some degree of this in
their life firsthand the pandemic drove
so many people
off the deep end and it was a real like
glimpse into how many people just
in General on any given day any given
moment in time how many people are right
there on the cusp of losing their
[ __ ] minds and all they need is a
little push and that pandemic was that
little push and some people just [ __ ]
lose their minds and they're gone
forever little push that's why they say
don't push me we have one of their
[ __ ] to try to tie in your own [ __ ]
yeah but we have one of our greatest
friends in the world that this happened
to I know so many people with their own
stories like this and dude that's what
happened to your [ __ ] friend yeah he
they it's like they use their minds and
they're just now they're [ __ ]
different people yeah it sucks the
amount of time the amount of time that I
like spent trying to like be friends and
make sure that these kinds of people
were okay it's just like Round Here it's
always on my mind
that's what you know what I mean I know
I know around here
okay because he looked at the guy in
counting Crow Counting Crows Adam duritz
or whatever the [ __ ] his name is dude
Adam dirt it's always on my mind when I
was in college Adam doors tried to [ __ ]
my girlfriend so many times so many
different ways oh my God I bet that was
a long December
yeah that's crazy dude yeah I'd love to
[ __ ] yeah
even though you have a boyfriend round
volunteer yeah yeah yeah stop okay yeah
yeah but I could be in the crowning
crows yeah yeah I guess I mean didn't
want one time he he [ __ ] actually I'm
completely making that up oh well it
sounds good sounded good
um um no but I I yeah it's not that
sucks bro but advice if there is any is
that
try to get
definitely take no responsibility for
this yourself this is all on those other
people and try to get used to the fact
that the pandemic
this has happened to one in one way or
another to everyone all the same people
have been touched one way or another by
the crazy people in ways like this and
you're not alone you
strong everyone who you're not alone
uh you so many people have been through
this okay you should
honestly if you're looking at it in the
Life rips way I always say life rips go
[ __ ] thank the pandemic go thank the
pandemic for cutting these people out of
your life in a quicker fashion than it
would have if that if if this virus
didn't exist dude yeah so it would have
been something if it wasn't this yeah it
would have been something and it would
have taken longer it would have caused
you more stress I get that the stress is
palpable now but go outside and say
thank you coven wow if you have a friend
that has I'm telling you to do it too
film it send it in go outside and say
covid think get on your knees like
Brendan [ __ ] Frazier in School Ties
wait till it rains thank you Coleman wow
wow that's a good movie do that [ __ ] man
because it's like [ __ ] it yo the you
cut hey covid did you make any did you
did you [ __ ] my friends up or did you
[ __ ] expose my enemies thank you
covered how much would you have [ __ ]
how much would it have sucked if this
guy was in your wedding and then
afterwards or some other [ __ ] happened
and then you would have had these
pictures and you would have been looking
at them all lonely just like one more
night in Hollywood right so get out
there and go thank you for exposing my
enemies coming well such a crazy person
like if you saw someone do that thank
you for exposing my enemies covid
Lifeline listener huh anybody that says
exposing my enemies in general is a
[ __ ] absolute nutcase completely
disagree dude that's why me and Tupac
are on the same team and you're on the
[ __ ] different side okay okay okay
now let's move on
we got a Facebook Minecraft
seeing a new guy a couple months ago I'm
33 and uh things have been going great
except for the fact that the last few
times we've had sex he has lost his
erection like mid-sex
um obviously initially I thought oh gosh
she's not attracted to me he swears up
and down that's not it
um that just biologically this happens
sometimes to men which I totally
understand however I you know my needs
aren't being met
so I would was wondering how do I bring
this up to him to maybe get this
resolved
um I don't want to emasculate him I want
to support him and
um I really care about him so I don't
want to hurt his feelings so how would
you suggest I bring this up to him it's
a new relationship should I be concerned
thanks guys
it's a little alarm that's happening
that it's a little loving what that
mouth do
that that's happening so early in a
relationship yeah but
get [ __ ] Viagra
yeah but also what that mouth do
and what exactly does this mean well you
know if he's getting soft in the middle
of doing the horizontal Mambo yeah you
turn to him and you say what that mouth
do and then what does that mean let's
see how it works
yeah and and yeah that's definitely true
yeah yeah okay
yeah so but so but also I let me say
this dude if I'm really into uh a woman
right like this has happened my whole
life if I'm really into her it's more of
a thing and it's uh more stress or
pressure for me to perform well and then
I get inside my head yeah and that could
happen to me deeper now I have intimacy
issues nice to meet you intimacy let's
have issues together but you know I you
know that that does happen so I would
trust him
and give him the benefit of that it is
not you right I can even tell with your
pixely face it's not you right but um
but yeah maybe kind of like
right like just
it's it's a tough thing to bring up but
maybe kind of just gently turn over to
them after you have sex one time and
just be like sweetie what what that
mouth do you know or say like how's your
tongue game or whatever the [ __ ] you
know what I mean anyway I think what you
should do is you're not gonna you want
to lap it up you're not gonna masculate
them if you came at him the way you just
describe
I'm talking about
oops right
how's the tongue game though like this
with the covers just like this
can you lap it up so gross though lap it
up like a [ __ ] dog yeah I've got a
dog bowl in between my legs stupid
what's up Doberman I got a [ __ ]
vanilla bean between my legs
oh yeah
um no I think first of all that's a good
idea this is his erection he can still
go down on you he still has a mouth he
has other ways of making you uh give
bringing delivering pleasure to you
robot
um but I also think that you're not
gonna necessarily masculate him he knows
what's happening he knows you know
what's happening all you got to do is
like mention it it's like the more you
don't mention it the weirder it gets
yeah but bring it up maybe it happens to
him maybe it's something that has
happened to him in the past it's a
recurring thing not talking about it at
all is a Surefire way to get it all
[ __ ] up yeah you'll get it all [ __ ]
up and you won't even get hard in the
beginning you'll just be like Viagra
trying to shoehorn it in Viagra is an
option for sure uh there are other more
natural ways of trying to keep an
erection uh but yeah definitely have him
start going down on you because if he's
losing his [ __ ] heart on
what up you ought to go down you got to
go down south well make her still happy
like one of my favorite things is to see
what a guy's mouth game is like so maybe
we can get into that and maybe don't
mention the [ __ ] soft [ __ ] you know
what am I you know one of my favorite
things is two of my favorite things
honestly badminton and seeing what other
guy's mouth game is did you want to try
any of those I have rackets but also
what kind of guy loses his heart on and
isn't like let me attempt at doing the
mouth game I mean probably many guys
he's probably insecure about trying a
mouth game maybe maybe his mouth maybe
he didn't do it yet we don't know how
new it is right if it's if it's like it
you know if it's like two or three times
or you know it's just a new relationship
so maybe if they're exclusive it's been
a bit but yeah and also maybe it's the
condom maybe you know some guys can't do
it with the comments that's true but you
know he would have said that if that she
would have said that if that was the
case
everybody's got a little dirt bag in
them all right okay but uh yeah dude
tell him to go down on you [ __ ] full
stop end of story end of sentences in a
paragraph end of [ __ ] short story and
a collection of short stories and a book
and a book binding
that's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
dude all right okay next one
Matthew Modine so I was in Band of
Brothers what do I do if what's up man
Chris
so I got a little situation here it's
gonna be so bad I'm currently talking to
this girl that I work with nothing I
know bad idea
but the problem is I'm
23.31 okay okay
outside of that we get along really well
and everything's going pretty smoothly
we've only been talking like three or
four months but recently she's been
talking about wanting to have a kid oh
my God now I probably don't want to have
a kid until you know a good 10 years
probably but I don't think
she's willing to wait 10 years I mean
who the [ __ ] is you know would that
would that means should I cut things off
sweetie should I keep just going with
the flow and see where things
head
I don't know we work together so that
could stir up some stuff in the already
did bro yeah I mean I doubt it she's a
sweetheart but uh could be yeah just let
me know what you guys think also they
haven't even had sex yet and she's
already talking about having kids no
they have it's been a few months run oh
yeah I thought he said they were texting
for a few months oh no no it's been
happening for a few months okay well
then they're already bro you already
made the mistake so [ __ ] whatever at
this point but um I mean you have a lot
of money because you're in Cutthroat
Island but uh yeah I don't know it's
great in Full Metal Jacket I think that
that was the one I was trying to think
of so uh I think that
I mean you know you can't be like how's
41 sound as a mother you know she would
literally her head would explode yeah
can you just wait 10 years props to her
yeah
props to her for being up front though
yeah for sure yeah that's absolutely
true so she was up front to you so you
should be up front of her I think no you
owe her that exactly so just say like yo
I'm not gonna want kids for another 10
years you want to ride this out or not I
totally get it but also uh
it's probably best if you guys just
don't keep it a cat if you keep it okay
but let me tell you something for real
this guy thinks I don't want kids for
another 10 years you don't know you
don't know yeah you don't know in two
years you could change your mind in 10
years you could still not want kids
there's no right way to approximate when
you think you will want children when
you think you you know you'll be ready
there's no way to know in fact you might
not ever be ready and then you might
have a kid and the day it comes you
think oh my God I'm so ready I can't
[ __ ] wait for this these things are
not knowable so get that part out of
your [ __ ] mind if you really are into
this woman and she's really into you and
you guys agree to not let it [ __ ] up the
workplace you already started doing it
you might as well see it through the end
to cut it now and be like no no we work
together you already dipped a toe and
you're [ __ ] that's true good point
what a good feeling man so just keep
going be a good guy be upfront with her
like she has been with you and be
[ __ ] honest and see where it goes
yeah I agree good good job dude good
good good good uh What do you call it
it's called advice
okay
hey what's up guys it's Alex from Boston
um I just hit record and I took a turn
and now I'm staring directly at the Sun
or anything but
um my question is basically uh I have a
new job and it's work from home forever
remote and my lease is going to end in
June and I basically have the
opportunity to work from anywhere and I
can't decide where to go so I figured
I'd ask you guys Chris you travel a lot
um Matt I'm sure you've done some
traveling so I'm just curious within the
us or maybe even Europe if you could
work from a home office anywhere wow
where would you do it oh wow wow damn
dude three years ago I would have said
La
um uh any word though if you if you
could here's the thing if you could be
anywhere and have a job that you like
that's tough dude that's so many there's
so many cool places what would you do
Shanghai no come on you said not China
what he said Europe
well the United States or Europe okay
fine
um I would maybe dude I would maybe go
to Pimpin pimp and ask Montreal Montreal
is great Montreal's a [ __ ]
opportunity
Vancouver is a little the thing about
Canada is you don't know where it's
going to be in five years what do you
mean they're [ __ ] changing faster
than we are bro they're so woke they're
crazy I mean
what all right but that's not a reason
to not go to [ __ ] Montreal if you
want to live there I guess not
um
um yeah I don't know man I mean there's
a lot of really great places Nashville's
great Boise is I mean there's places you
wouldn't even think of you know Boise
um well you know a lot of different
cities where would you go if you were
just a single guy starting brand new guy
um
and then location didn't matter like
being in La yeah being a comic that
wasn't the thing like it was just
Total Clean Slate Austin's cool I mean
you know it's growing rapidly though you
always got to be careful about that I
would maybe want to be someplace that's
like
as close to Country City and Country
being as close as possible to one
another which actually in many ways is
La but LA's right now is not the time
for La yeah I know it's not it probably
will be again in the near future but
right now is not I'm trying to think of
places uh Florida's awesome because of
the weather
what about any place in Georgia that
stuff
they're not Rally a lot
Raleigh is really nice yeah you know
what's really nice is um
Raleigh yeah he's nice
yeah uh I would say [ __ ] Montreal
would be mine though for real really I
really love Montreal Jesus I like love
Montreal Toronto whenever I take a
flight away from Montreal I have a crazy
Zenny Island trip right right Toronto is
awesome
um
I've never been to Toronto really yeah
isn't that weird yeah that is weird
um where else have I been and where am I
going
I mean so introspective hmm
I could go anywhere Colorado places it's
okay yeah it's not my channel but I like
Denver yeah but it's not my thing though
Colorado is really pretty yeah really
really pretty and the weather's bad but
not like
this has Seasons you know
where else Chicago's like [ __ ] crazy
right ice icebergs it gets too cold
there for me I'll be in Chicago February
25th [ __ ] himself
um New York's cool but it's expensive
it's a little too much yeah I wouldn't
go to New York for a few years already
but if you haven't lived in New York
actually I would say maybe go to try New
York because it's some a place some
people just truly fall in love with I
loved it while I was there Fort
Lauderdale School Fort Lauderdale yeah
um
400 really um
looking at different places uh uh I'm
not Mr Florida you like like Arizona and
[ __ ] though oh yeah oh Phoenix and Tempe
is [ __ ] awesome I love it
Phoenix I'm looking at places what a
loser uh Phoenix and Tempe is awesome
um
what about like uh well that kind of
costs a bit of money did he say he's
been Rich no he didn't okay I mean you
know everybody does say Nashville I
think Nashville might be the move for
everybody the problem with the place
like Nashville and Austin is they're
very they're really growing really fast
and you don't know what the [ __ ] it's
going to become that's true yeah but
yeah uh what did I say Fort Lauderdale
is [ __ ] awesome all right all the
places in the [ __ ] United States for
a single dude Fort Lauderdale is awesome
and Europe uh
all right
um singing uh Madrid
okay you know
all right next one
wow
guys so serious it gets in so many
fights what's up man Chris coming at you
poolside from Dubai wow I had a question
mainly for Chris if I recall correctly
on the congratulations pod used to
always complain about lower back
problems say things along the lines of
is my back really hurt yes can I barely
move yes does life still rip yes
worst impression ever and um
wanted to just understand how you got
rid of that because I've been trying
everything still has still have pretty
consistent lower back issues and wanted
to know how you resolved that because
you don't really complain about it
anymore and as a final note we moving up
look at that bro
God is that where Tom Cruise ran down I
don't know yeah yeah it is right yeah
yeah that's a famous that's like the
tallest building in the world right now
wow that's crazy yeah
um so just took the video to do that you
know I mean yeah it doesn't yeah
um
I um I don't yeah I you know what you
know what the unfortunate thing is you
gotta wait that's back that that's back
[ __ ] you just gotta wait yeah like I
waited I thought about having surgery I
I had one it was that bad I had a
procedure done where they injected
something and if I just waited it out it
would have been fine and it's fine now
um but you know I still do I guess I
still feel it
I completely I completely forgot about
it though I had severe middle back pain
like just yeah right off my spine under
behind my shoulder blade it [ __ ] went
away yeah yeah but I have that [ __ ] for
years you get stretching helps for sure
just helped the [ __ ] out of me like
consistent weekly like deep tissue tie
like crazy miniature Thai woman who are
the strongest people on Earth yeah just
like elbows just [ __ ] like
like purple people eat or whatever the
[ __ ] is gonna say yeah uh yeah but
that's what's up yeah I don't know I
think that it's like um you gotta uh
just stretch and wait I don't know
what's wrong with you if you actually
have something wrong if it's not just a
muscle thing yeah then get it looked at
and then X-ray and [ __ ] like if you
crunched your discs and [ __ ] I mean if
it's a bone thing good luck it's never a
bumping though but if it's just spine
you're [ __ ] forever but the guy I
think he's [ __ ] forever
uh yeah no he's just get deep massages
by [ __ ] Miniatures really strong
Taiwan all right well you know that's
what that's what helped me dude I'm
telling you but I don't know if the race
matters but no it does because that's
where they practice it in games I know
yeah right yeah
um so anyway that's what you got to do
and also wait time is your friend wait
it out uh speaking of time in one week
four days I guess Wednesday uh October
19th Matt's birthday show watch
lifeline.com the link is under here in
the comments you can do our join our
live show and get tickets 6 p.m Pacific
October 19th watch lifetime.com we're
gonna be taking your calls live we're
gonna be talking with you we're gonna
get in depth and [ __ ] you can get
advices that way and have back and forth
with you and us and special guests and
sign merch and surprise other things yes
yep there we go so that's what's up go
get your Lifeline merch at La watch
lifeline.com and support the show we
love it you guys have been great go to
chrisley.com for um
tickets for my tour and peace out and go
to magically.com for your private
section with me
I don't like you doing that
I know I don't like it hello hello
[Music]
hello hello
[Music]